ap les six lors d'un référendum il hier
pour entériner une révision
constitutionnelle censée fonder une
nouvelle république
elle les algériens ont boudé massivement
les eurent le taux de participation
final nos élèves qui à 23,7 pour cent
les partisans de l'irak mouvement de
contestation prenait le boycott tandis
que les islamistes du pays ont appelé à
voter non à des incidents ont eu lieu en
kabylie où de nombreux à bureaux de vote
n'ont pas ouvert dans cette région
traditionnellement traditionnellement
frondeuse à des interpellations ont eu
lieu à alger à tizi ouzou grand absent
du scrutin le président algérien 74 ans
il est hospitalisé depuis mercredi en
allemagne pour des examens approfondis
après l'annnonce de cas suspects
coronavirus dans son entourage
et voyez l'analyse de kader abderrahim
directeur de recherche à l'institut
prospective et sécurité en europe et
auteur de l'ouvragé aux politiques de
l'algérie aux éditions bibliomonde il ya
peu de changements peu d'avancé c'est un
système présidentiel qui accentue encore
ses prérogatives et le présidente bonne
ne fait pas exception par rapport aux
constitutions précédentes ni à celle de
bouteflika ni à celle de ses
prédécesseurs
par conséquent ça change pas grand chose
l'enjeu véritable en réalité était
d'étouffer à travers ce référendum
d'étouffer les manifestants du rac
mais il est clair aujourd'hui que la la
couverture médiatique notamment de la
presse internationale de ce référendum
constitutionnel a permis aux attaques de
se faire entendre
ou plus exactement de se faire
réentendre et de ramener au devant de la
scène les revendications des algériens
ce référendum sera adopté même si la
participation des algériens est très
très basse s'il n'y a eu aucun
engouement pour cette consultation
mais il faudra bien que le prénom de la
république signe le décret d'application
du référendum
or s'il est empêché parce qu'il est
soigné à l'étranger
ça va être délicat ça va être difficile